WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SUNDAY
SHOW.
THE WHITE HOUSE REVIEW --
REVERSE.
THIS COMES AS SIX STATES ARE
SUING THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OVER ITS FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
JOE BIDEN IS DOUBLING DOWN.
>> WE CAN AFFORD TO CANCEL
$10,000 OF STUDENT DEBT AND
20,000 BUCKS IF YOU HAD A PELL
GRANT.
MAKING UNDER 125 GRAND.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR WORD FROM
THOSE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHOSE
FAMILIES GOT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN SEVERAL OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN PANDEMIC
RELIEF LOAN FORGIVENESS.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
COME ON.
>> GIVE ME A BREAK.
I THINK THIS IS A MISTAKE.
ULTIMATELY YOU HAVE MORE PEOPLE
MAD THAT THEY WAFTED PAY FOR
OTHER PEOPLE GETTING TERRIBLE
DEGREES THAT THEY WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO PAY THEM OFF AND THE
OTHERS RECEIVING THE BENEFITS.
>> IT IS A MISTAKE.
FIRST OF ALL, HE DOES NOT HAVE
THE EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY TO DO
THIS.
JUST WAVING AWAY THIS DEBT.
THE CHANGING RULES, THAT IS AN
ADMISSION.
THESE RULES ARE CONTRACTING
FASTER THAN ARMY HAMMERS DATING
POOL.
THEY ARE INVOKING SOMETHING
CALLED THE QUIROZ ACT.
IT WAS A 2003 ACT AND IT ALLOWS
THE SECRETARY OF EDUCATION TO
WAIVE A REFORM STUDENT AID
PROGRAMS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
OUT OF THIS ENTIRELY.
I WILL NOT GRIND ON THE
REPUBLICANS TODAY, BUT I WILL.
THEY SHOULD BE MELTING DOWN
THESE FEDERAL AGENCIES.
THAT IS WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
CALLING FOR.
THE EDUCATION DEPARTMENT IS A
CLASSIC EXAMPLE BECAUSE THIS
KIND OF MISCHIEF IS WHAT ENSUES
WHEN THE PRESIDENT HAS SO MUCH
DOMINION.
SOME OF THAT LAND HAS TO
CONTRACT FOR BIDEN AND SO MANY
OTHERS.
ANITA: WE NEED TO GET RID OF SO
MANY AGENCIES.
HOW DOES IT GO OVER?
>> JUST ADD THEM TO THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE MAD.
THE ONES THAT ALREADY PAID THEIR
STUDENT LOANS BACK.
A LOT OF VERY UPSET PEOPLE.
JUST BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR JUST A MINUTE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
REQUIRED UNDER THE LAW TO
COLLECT THE BALANCE OF THESE
LOANS.
THE QUESTION IS, DOES THE
PRESIDENT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
OVERRIDE IT.
THEY SAY NO IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYS, YES, THEY
DO.
>> PANDEMIC OVER IN ITS PREMISED
ON THE FACT THAT THERE IS A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
JIMMY, I SAY BEST ONE FOR YOU.
THERE IS ANOTHER MAJOR REVERSAL
FROM EMMA KRATZ.
A BILL THAT WOULD HAVE LIMITED
HOW MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CAN
TRADE THE STOCK MARKET.
I WONDER WHY.
>> SHE IS CRITICIZING THE
FAILURE TO BRING IT UP.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE VOTES TO
BRING IT UP.
>> WE DON'T GO FROM ONE DAY TO
THE NEXT.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
LEGISLATION.
>> HER HUSBAND HAS BEEN CAUGHT.
THE NEW YORK TIMES ALSO FOUND
THAT NEARLY 20% OF MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS REPORTED TRADES AND
COMPANIES INFLUENCED BY THEIR
COMMITTEES.
GO ON.
WE TOOK A POLL WHEN WE WERE
PASSING A MASS MASHED POTATOES.
DEFINITELY DOES NOT WANT TO SEE
THIS THING FROM HAPPENING.
EVERY AMERICAN THINKS THAT THIS
IS A SCAM.
MAKING $170,000 A YEAR.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
HOW DO WE HAVE 87,000 IRS AGENTS
TO LOOK AT MY TAXI DRIVING
RECEIPTS FROM 2012.
THEY DID NOT LET THEM PROXY VOTE
90,000 PAGES.
YOU GET UP THE NIGHT BEFORE.
USUALLY UNDER A FAKE NAME.
>> THEY ARE TOO BUSY VACATIONING
IN FRANCE AND LYING AB